there was a guy who is a video going
around the Internet of a guy who use
rough language he talked that you know I
not that sort of thing we would want to
emulate necessarily but I think what he
was expressing is what a lot of us are
feeling right now
which is he was he was just shopping
minding his own business and in some
stores now it's not enough that you have
to wear the mask and I don't know
perform all these weird rituals you
actually have to walk following arrows
through the store so let's say you're
walking you know you're you walk past
the the pasta aisle and you get into the
bread aisle but then you realize oh wait
I forgot I need some spaghetti so you
turn around you walk back three feet
they scream at you they get so crazy all
of these people who are on such an
hysterical edge from the coronavirus
alarmism so this woman decides to start
filming this guy for now imagine that
walking up to a stranger and just
filming them for no reason and this guy
goes off he reminds us why increasingly
it seems the laymen are wiser than the
experts take a picture of me that make
you feel better why don't you get a life
and that's going around taking pictures
mayor's asked us all to wear masks and
look at you not wearing a mask it's a
political it's unbelievable now you have
accosted me in this store that I got to
where you're gonna keep this up maybe
we'll get the police department you call
911 then yeah yeah go on another one you
people are like monkeys I'm out of a
tree now you're the monkey that has it
painted by evolution
why don't you go back to where you won't
you need are you burning crosses are you
burning crosses great interaction
absolutely terrific it illustrates so
much of what we're seeing now which is
this guy is minding his own business
buying something in a store not a
costing anybody and some lunatic woman
to actually start filming him because
he's not performing the very specific
political rituals that we've been told
for the past few weeks we have to
perform but a few weeks ago those same
people who tell us we have to perform
when told us we shouldn't perform namely
wearing the masks walking in the right
directions and when he says lady you're
acting crazy this is not normal behavior
to go up to people and start filming
them because they're not shopping for
groceries in exactly the way that you
want this is crazy stuff what does she
says she goes you don't know science you
probably don't believe in evolution
you probably don't listen to what the
exalted dr. foul she you don't she she
loves a political attack that is cloaked
as science and that is what I presume
this woman is of the left I presume
she's a Democrat this is what her
national political leader leaders are
doing all the time and yet there is more
wisdom in this layman's gut than in all
of the pseudo scientific knowledge and
credentials of that crazy lady of the
left
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description